So every year, you know, for the
July rolls around, fireworks,
barbecues, the whole 9 yards.
It's such a core American thing,
right?
Celebrating independence.
But what if the story we tell
ourselves about that
independence and maybe other big
moments too?
What if it's not quite the whole
picture?
Our mission today in this deep
dive is really to explore that.
A fascinating, maybe sometimes
uncomfortable look back.
A kind of re evaluation of
American origins, challenging
that that lone cowboy myth we've
all grown up with.
Yeah, and we're drawing on some
really thought provoding stuff
today, sources like a
Declaration of Interdependence
and another called the
Revolution as a prototype Color
Revolution.
Plus this really interesting
mind experiment piece.
They offer this fresh, maybe
even a bit radical perspective
on what independence really
means.
And you know how America might
just well tend to forget its
hidden helpers, as they put it.
So yeah, get ready to maybe see
history through a a pretty
different lens.
OK, so let's unpack that.
The first thing that jumps out,
especially from that Declaration
of Interdependence source, is
this idea about the what it
calls the lone cowboy myth, the
genius tinkerer myth, the self
rescuing Superman myth.
I mean, that feels so deeply
ingrained in our national
identity.
So how do these sources argue
that picture might be, well,
incomplete?
Well, what they really highlight
so effectively is that two
things can be true at once,
right?
Independence is absolutely
precious, something you cherish,
you defend, of course.
But America, in its founding
moments and actually beyond, it
just didn't achieve its
successes alone, not really.
The piece uses this great
analogy, actually, I think of a
Nobel laureate, right, Standing
alone on stage, getting the
prize.
What you don't see, the author
says, is the graveyard of used
pipettes behind them.
All those unacknowledged
contributions, you know, lab
assistants, technicians,
countless others.
That graveyard of pipettes,
that's a really powerful and it
really makes you think.
So, OK, applying that, then,
where do we start seeing these
hidden helpers in the actual
history, especially somewhere as
foundational as the American
Revolution?
Because I know the sources
really dig into France's role,
which, as they say, often gets
kind of memory hold.
I can almost hear Matt Chrome,
you know, looking back and Riley
saying AM Don't forget our Navy
bailed your powderless colonial
butts out of the Chesapeake.
Oh absolutely, it's so true.
And the scale of French help,
it's actually kind of
astonishing when you really look
at it.
I mean, take Yorktown 1781.
Admiral de Grasse, his French
fleet outnumbered the Royal Navy
there.
Outnumbered them.
Yeah, completely blockaded.
Cornwallis sealed his fate
effectively.
And it wasn't just ships.
Rochambeau's French troops were
right there fighting alongside
Washington's guys.
And if you zoom out, the whole
spirit, liberty, equality,
fraternity, that's deep French
Enlightenment influence,
Rousseaux, Voltaire, Montescu,
right?
The philosophical underpinnings.
Totally.
Ben Franklin was practically
living in Paris, brokering these
crucial loans, which came,
ironically, from a King Louis
the 6th, an absolute monarch.
But, well, he hated England
more.
Politics makes strange
bedfellows.
Doesn't it just?
And then, of course, there's the
Statue of Liberty.
A gift from France, A literal
monument to those shared
republican ideals.
Hard to ignore.
OK, so the revolution definitely
had these huge external
influences.
Does this pattern, this hidden
helpers thing, does it pop up
elsewhere?
What about something like, say,
World War 2?
Because the sources have this
incredibly provocative line,
imagining like the ghost of
Zhukov or maybe Putin today
tapping his medals and saying
him, We lost more people in one
city than you lost in the entire
European theater.
Yeah, that one that really
forces you to adjust your
perspective, doesn't it?
The numbers are just staggering.
Soviet deaths in World War 2
estimates range from 20 to maybe
27 million people. 20 million.
Good grief.
It's almost impossible to grasp
and just look at Stalingrad,
that battle alone 2,000,000
casualties, Axis and Soviet
combined.
The article really emphasizes
this.
The meat grinder of the Eastern
Front made D-Day possible.
So without that sacrifice.
Exactly.
So the source suggests when
you're standing on Normandy
beach, you know, squinting into
the distance, you should also be
seeing the smoke from Stalingrad
and Kursk.
Same war, same enemy, same
planet.
It's all connected.
That definitely puts a different
spin on things.
Wow.
But then the sources take it
even further, and this is where
it got really interesting, maybe
a little uncomfortable for me.
They argue this isn't just about
the revolution in WWII, it's
almost like a recurring habit.
America treating foreign help
like a like a shameful second
cousin you don't talk about.
What other kinds of hidden
helpers do they mention that we
tend to gloss over?
Oh, the list is surprisingly
long when you start looking.
The sources mentioned things
like hidden stockpiles of
foreign cash that bankrolled key
moments, borrowed ships, you
know, bolstering naval power
when needed, critical
intelligence leaks coming from
unexpected allies, even Hessian
mercenaries.
Turns out some were turned by
bribes to fight for the American
side.
Not against it, really, I.
Didn't know that, yeah.
And then you've got the German
scientists acquired, let's say
after WWII for the rocket
programs, native scouts whose
crucial help is often just
erased later, even Mexican
cavalry in some border
conflicts.
And you might ask, OK, So what?
Why care about this history all?
Right.
What's the take away for today?
Well, the sources put it pretty
bluntly.
When you forget your helpers,
you stop being worth helping.
Oof.
That's correct.
It is, but it's a powerful point
about reciprocity and maybe
historical honesty.
It really is something to sit
with, especially, you know, on
days when we celebrate our
self-sufficiency.
But then, OK, one of the other
sources, the revolution as a
prototype color revolution.
This introduces what I found to
be a genuinely mind bending
idea.
A mind experiment they call it.
What if America's birth wasn't
just heroic patriots rising up,
but was also, in a way, one of
history's first really
successful color revolutions?
My first reaction was just wait,
but that can't be right.
How do we even begin to unpack
that?
It's definitely a challenging
frame, no doubt, but that's kind
of the point, right?
To make us rethink.
So first they define what a
color revolution means in mono
perms.
It's basically when an outside
power encourages funds, maybe
shapes a local rebellion to
weaken a rival power, but
without actually fighting them
directly.
OK, so like the CIA may be
backing student protest
somewhere?
Or funneling cash and weapons?
Yeah, training guerrillas.
Exactly that kind of thing.
It's proxy war or regime change,
just with a different label
sometimes.
Right.
So if we apply that lens back to
1776, the Boston Tea Dumpers,
the Minutemen, they become the
sort of local spark, the organic
St. movement, right, that France
then cleverly leveraged.
Is that the idea?
That's precisely the lens the
source asks us to try on.
And when you look at it that
way, France's role it becomes
absolutely central.
Not just helpful, but maybe even
strategic in a different way.
You've got Louis the 6th again,
the absolute monarch sending
shiploads of muskets, cannons,
powder, gold.
Material support.
Massive and French Freemasons,
Enlightenment thinkers actively
flooding the colonies with
radical pamphlets.
Liberty, fraternity, all that.
Their fleet blockading the
British at Yorktown.
We talked about that and the
huge loans that basically
bankrolled the whole thing.
So France's motive wasn't just
pure revolutionary idealism.
Well, their main motive,
according to this view, was
pretty clear.
Bloody England's nose for
colonial revenge and supporting
the American cause was frankly a
brilliant way to do it without a
full scale direct war initially.
OK, So what does this
interpretation mean then?
Where Americans, as the source
puts it, patriots, yes, but also
proxies Useful idiots in Whigs?
That phrase useful idiots?
Wow, that's pretty stark.
What does this suggest when we
look at, say, modern conflicts?
It's provocative, for sure.
And the source suggests, yeah,
maybe the American Revolution
was the prototype, the first
modern lab for how you fund,
train and arm a local
insurrection to exhaust your
enemy without a direct clash.
Now, importantly, this doesn't
diminish the bravery or the
ideals of the revolutionaries.
Not at all.
Right.
It's not saying they weren't
genuine patriots.
Exactly.
It just makes it, well, real, as
the source says, more complex.
Independence is rarely pure.
Liberty is often someone else's
leverage.
History is messy like that.
And yeah, they draw parallels.
Redcoats then versus maybe
Russian troops in Ukraine now.
Or think about the Soviets in
Afghanistan facing Stinger
missiles gifted by Langley.
Or America funding various
covert actions.
You know, from Iran back in the
day to Latin in America, it's a
recurring pattern in
geopolitics.
And to really hammer home that
proxy war idea, one source
suggests looking at the
revolution like like the Afghan
Mujahideen in the 80s.
So the colonial militias are the
local fighters, passionate but
maybe outgunned.
The Brito empire is the big
occupying force like the Soviets
were in Afghanistan and France.
France is the outside power,
like the CIA back then,
providing the crucial weapons,
the money, the training, the
naval blockade.
It's a really uncomfortable
comparison for a lot of people,
understandably.
But it does highlight the
mechanics, doesn't it?
The reliance on external
support.
And it brings us back to the
point that without France's huge
loans, fleet blockades and
ground troops, those brave
farmers with pitchforks, however
heroic, likely wouldn't have
forced that surrender at
Yorktown.
So the war was.
Well, arguably as much a French
a proxy war against the British
as the Afghan War was a Cold War
proxy to drain the USSR.
Which definitely raises some big
questions about how we
understand our own history, our
own triumphs.
Yeah, it really ties it all
together, doesn't it?
This idea from the sources that
being a quote grown up patriot
means remembering the lab was
crowded.
It's not about downplaying the
achievement, but seeing the
whole complicated picture of how
it actually happened.
Exactly.
And the world is still crowded.
It's still interdependent,
acknowledging that it's not just
some historical exercise, right?
It's actually pretty key to
understanding how things work
today.
If you ignore it, you risk
misjudging things pretty badly,
both looking back and looking
forward.
So maybe as you look at those
fireworks this 4th, or just
think about American history,
here's that final provocative
thought from the sources to
maybe Mull over if the American
Revolution was in some
significant ways the first great
proxy war, maybe the first major
color revolution.
What does that suggest about the
lab we run today and conflicts
around the globe?
And maybe more importantly, when
the next proxy fight emerges, do
we even remember who watched our
beakers last time?